léon bürger que l'on mange en quelques
minutes assis ou bien debout devant une
petite desserte la mode des hamburgers
frites ce qu'on appelle la restauration
rapide nous vient d'amérique
de plus en plus de gens pressés qu'ils
ne veulent pas en outre dépenser trop
tôt trop d'argent pour leur repas
s'alimente fréquemment ainsi le point
sur la home bürger man in the cloud
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
conagra coupe cheese burger king kenny
kingfish apple ties and of french france
sans oublier la boisson coq milkshake ce
coffee shops in america nous nous sommes
en france à paris mais cette scène
aurait pu être filmée dans de grandes
villes de province la rampe
rahmani a conquis droit de cité au pays
du steak frites et du pot-au-feu
faites votre choix et deux minutes après
pour moins de quinze pan une food and
love une hôtesse vous servir à votre
fast food comprenez repas rapides sur un
plateau et elle vous donnera en prime un
sourire
alors que signifie manger à l'américaine
c'est pas seulement les hommes ont germé
frites
beignets aux pommes
typiquement
des états unis j'ai fait que nous là bas
même aux états unis
son meilleur ici
cent dix sept mille hamburgers sont
avalés quotidiennement en france
comment expliquer une telle réussite
nous avons
transposer la méthode américaine en
france sans hésiter au cas d'agression
est-ce qu'il s'agit d'une mode
oui je pense qu'il y a une certaine mode
de la nourriture américaine
il ya un certain nombre de gens qui
mange un hamburger comme il porte un
jean
je sors
à
qu'est ce qu'une plaie plus en l'ordre
ver s la viande est hachée ou bien
est-ce les condiments on y ajoute je
crois que c'est un tout c'est un produit
complet lorsqu'on parle hamburger à me
revient toujours clean propreté pas de
cuisinier mais des managers cela est
arrivé sur leur montre que respecter une
règle d'or va plus de deux minutes entre
le moment où la vie en a chez sort du
congélateur pour être cuite par et
d'oignons de cornichons de rondelles de
tomates et de sauce et celui où il est
remis au client
le jean se sont très bien adaptés aux
produits ce qui en avaient besoin
ils avaient besoin d'un repas rapides ce
qu'on leur serve des zonards par crop
tous nos produits sont emballés ont fait
selon des méthodes très hygiénique
ils avaient besoin d'un repas qui
pouvait éventuellement manger sur place
ou emporter à l'extérieur ce qui est le
cas et à des prix abordables bien sûr
pour 15 francs environ
vous pouvez manger un repas complet
chaud et à n'importe quelle heure du
jour ou des nids en fait les français
qui ont adopté la rambo rigueur manille
au but à 2 critères rapidité économie
jeudi soir et puis c'est pas plus cher
que d'acheter
c'est surtout très rapide ça sert
on est désolé tout de suite tout
on est restés eux
deux minutes à la caisse
jeu rapide
on y est
on
et des prix abordables qu'on peut
respecter non pas en rognant sur la
qualité mais étant donné que nous avons
un très gros volume on arrive à obtenir
des prix très intéressants
[Musique]
en conclusion la hamburger manille c'est
un déjeuner dépannage mais le temps
n'est pas encore venu où l'on achètera
des kings burger pour les déguster chez
soi en regardant la télévision par
exemple
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]